there are 10 things you missed on your
way to sell Dora shortcuts to each thing
are in the description and the game we
play is that you leave a dislike if you
know everything and alike if you learn
something new let's get into it
we'll start off easy hate back stabs me
- what you need is a clingy partner
attached to you who negates all damage
from the back this is the effect of an
incredible ring hidden in new game+ of
the shaded woods ascetic the Fork Road
bonfire and dash to the right as soon as
you enter the woods hug the wall and the
first corpse you encounter will have
Gowans ring it's incredible for use in
PvP
it makes the ancient dragon a cakewalk
and even in the shaded woods itself it
prevents you from getting backstabbed to
hell and back
now personally I don't need this item
because I'm a pro at Dark Souls 2 you
see there parry but you guys might want
it because it does help in this area so
while I proved my last point watch me
hit this tree with my anvil on a stick
you might not have noticed but these
larger trees have faces on them and they
groan if they're hit that's number two
speaking of trees number three is within
the boss fight with Nazca you notice
this tree with an item atop it and
you're like I want that that's got to be
a good item right it's in the boss room
after all so you go and hit the tree
with your anvil on a stick nothing
happens and you're like oh I get it
I'd probably have to risk my life during
a boss fight in this difficult game and
get the boss to knock it down so you
wait for koala 2.0 to go underground and
you purposefully get hit by her near the
tree and at this point suspense is so
high all you're thinking is oh this item
is going to be so good I'm almost dead
it has to be and you pick it up and
you're right
you just got yourself some flame
butterflies congratulations dude these
are so useful Dark Souls as you may have
guessed is a really dark game and it's
not like the developer removed a
lighting system before release that
actually made the game properly dark
adding to the ambience atmosphere and
gameplay making the decision to go with
or without a torch a decision that could
either result in timid exploration of
the dark or confident exploration of a
light area with your ability to block
removed is it yeah I don't think those
flame butterflies are worth it anyway
number 4 is after nudge go in the
hallway with the goblin clone he throws
these axes that will destroy you in one
hit if they connect but did you know
that you can do the incredibly risky
thing of hitting them out of the
err before they hit you looks cool so do
it if you have someone watching you or
if you're doing a top 10 about tidbits
you might have missed in Dark Souls 2
but otherwise you should probably just
sidestep them I saw this in one of the
early gameplay trailers for Dark Souls 2
and was actually glad to see that
they're kept in the game unlike a
certain lighting system am i right I
mean what's the point of torches if I
can just make the brightness slider
larger it's okay calm down moving on
again number 5 is the final encounter
with Payton Crichton that you'll find in
the first hut of the first cliff you can
jump off if you've progressed their
storylines this far and found them both
throughout the game and they'll be
engaging and fight to the death here in
this room whoever you helped will give
you their armor set and the key to a
room that holds the engraved gauntlets
which give you a 5% chance to get a
critical strike on your attacks another
did you know is that the story of Payton
Crichton is essentially the story of
patches and low track which is a rivalry
mirrored in every souls game to date
Pete hates Crichton and vice-versa
everyone on forums always asks who the
best character to help is from a moral
point of view and the answer is neither
of them just kill them both and get
their armor number 6 is probably the
most obscure secret in any Souls game
seriously down here in the abandoned
chapel with all the spiders on the
ceiling you'll find these mushrooms now
instantly it should click with you you
should know what to do pigs like
mushrooms what if I lead one of the pigs
down this treacherous path and see if he
eats them uncovering a rare weapon the
path I'm taking here was actually the
easiest way I found to do it and I even
used the dagger so I could effectively
control the pigs jumps though we've been
told that you can actually make the pigs
jump by themselves if you go down first
so you might want to try that out too
use the red eye ring if you want to make
it a bit easier increase their aggro
range but anyway once you get to the
mushrooms just watch the pig uncover
your reward the problem with this is
just like the flame butterflies on the
top of the tree that nudge could
destroys the reward is [ __ ] terrible
you get the pickaxe which has a boring
move set and mediocre damage it's a neat
little easter egg but it would have been
a more exciting discovery for the
community if it wasn't within the
official guide I think someone might
have realized that pigs dig up
things in real life and that people
historically have used them to hunt
truffles which is exactly what the boar
is doing here this next one is a bonus
thing for this video because I'm
narrating it now before I've actually
even recorded it that's because it's the
rarest event in a souls game and I can't
guarantee that I'll even be able to
record it according to the guide again
there's a 1 in 1,000 chance that a
little friendly piglet will spawn
outside the tent in the Royal Army
campsite he'll also eat the mushrooms if
you can find him but no other purpose
has been found for this little guy as of
yet number 7 is a pretty awesome event
that happens if you're going through the
game in new game+ Freya will
preemptively climb up this cliff face
and try to kill you for about 30 or 40
seconds before retreating I'm not
actually sure whether it's possible to
kill her here many people have noted
that she can retreat if she takes a
certain amount of damage too fast
although I'm not 100% sure about that
the good thing is that her lost health
will carry over to the final fight with
her making her new game+ encounter a
little bit easier but her having less
health isn't actually useful for me
because I'm going to try and heal Freya
in our final fight with her for number 8
this is necessary so we can make both of
her heads fall off so if you hit one
head enough during the fight it will fly
off and be able to be kicked around the
arena all the little spiders will flee
from this so if you're actually having
trouble with Freya you can focus on one
head and have a pretty good strategy
there because all the little spiders
will run away but if you heal her up
with the pyromancy spell warmth or use a
really weak weapon then did you know
that you can actually get both heads to
fall off the only actual reason for
doing this is a if you're doing a top 10
series based around interesting Dark
Souls 2 bits or B if you're an [ __ ]
white phantom who wants to heal bosses
so that your hosts can't defeat them if
both the Freya's heads fall off then
she's completely unkillable and will
spam this flail attack ad infinitum but
if you don't have an [ __ ] summon who
heals Freya then once you defeat her and
acquire the ashen mist heart you can
actually come back here and access
dragon memories I know this is common
knowledge for a lot of you but for those
who don't read the forum's it's probably
not so did you know that you can
actually enter this location it's a
reference to
the extinction of the ancient dragons in
the prologue of Dark Souls 1 and you can
get an ancient dragon soul from this
encounter use this soul to craft the
curved dragon great sword through
weaponsmith own effects the final thing
to find towards Eldora is the cage in
duke's eldora's study we know that the
duke was overly fond of spiders to the
point where they over ran his town and
he just sat aside and watched eerily
contented many speculate that the cage
housed some sort of spider that might
have become Freya and they speculate
this with good reason even though if it
was a spider it could have fell through
the cracks anyway if you want to learn
about that story then you can click here
to watch story mode which is an
exploration of the law aspects of an
area this episode is on tell Dora which
is leading up to the first proper
prepare to cry video that will take
place in this area because this area
regardless of what you might think
actually has a cast of great characters
to talk about so hopefully you guys get
to see that in a few weeks I hope you
enjoyed this one and I'll see you next
time bye bye
you